- But you also host a new Netflix show
and it's called "BS the Game Show", right?
- Yes, I do.
- Is this like BS like
the show that I know
from like childhood, like-
- I don't, I wasn't around your childhood.
- Well, you missed out.
- So I don't know the game that you
- On all my tricycles.
(both laugh)
- But it, BS is the best
game I've ever been part of.
I like it as much, if not
more than "Deal or No Deal".
'Cause it's got those elements too.
- Yeah.
- I don't like trivia.
I'm not smart.
I don't have a GED.
- I don't agree with the "I'm
not smart" thing, but yes go.
- Well I'm telling, well,
tell every teacher that ever
tried to educate me how smart I am.
- But that just means you're different.
You learn differently.
- I'm different.
- Yeah.
- But so I'm different. Thank you.
- I'm different. Yeah.
- Two differents make a-
- I just pressed my
breast against your back.
I'm different.
(laughs)
I think it qualifies.
- You think you're
different, but wherever I go
that's what happens to me.
- (laughs)
- Anyway.
- Getting coffee.
So wait, so what's the game?
- So, so my, my point is
that you don't have to know the answers.
- Okay.
- You just have to convince one person
- Yeah.
- That you know the answer.
So, and you win the money
- So you BS your way.
- Pardon me?
- You BS your way through it
- You can.
- Okay.
Isn't that amazing?
Isn't that how we get in through life?
So you watch the show,
not to try to figure
out the trivia questions
- Yeah.
- To look at people's face and go
she doesn't know what she's talking about.
(audience laughs)
- Were you a good BS-er
in like high school
or any time, are you good at BS-ing?
- I think I am.
I think most of my life I am.
I think I'm, you know,
because on a serious note
because of my mental
health issues, you know,
I'm neurotic and I have OCD and I have.
So people think that I'm
happy and enjoying myself
and I'm out and I'm amongst people.
- And you're, you're not.
- It's bold.
No, I'm scared.
And I, I like to go at home
and just live in the fetal position.
- It's so funny to me
because like every time I'm
around you, like even
- I'm a joy
- Seeing you like out of work.
- I know isn't this amazing.
- Yeah, know what I'm saying,
like you're so the opposite
of what I would think
- I know.
- Okay.
- I know I'm such a joy
and a light, so much energy.
- You are!
- And I'm stunning.
- No, but even-
- The thing is-
- Like when we saw each
other and you come to a show
like we were both, you were outside
of work and you're,
it's so funny to me because I would
think you are so confident.
- So my family
and me are huge fans and I was
working in Vegas and I came
and saw you in Las Vegas
because we loved the concert.
- And you were perfectly awesome.
- I love to, I love to come see you.
And we love the concert and we love you.
You gotta see her live.
- But you weren't neurotic.
(Crowd cheers and claps)
- You have to see her live. I am.
- You were, you were awesome.
- I'll be honest with you.
I'm incredibly medicated.
- (laughs)
Aren't we all?
- I don't know.
- (laughs) I am.
- It's so funny to me though.
I just, I think from the outside,
we always think we know
what's going on with people
and you just really, truly don't.
- You don't know.
- Yeah.
- You don't know. I'm a mess.
- But you don't think like being in,
this is a real question.
You don't think like
being in an industry where
you have so many fans,
so many people love you.
Like you don't, that
doesn't change any that,
or aid any of that at all?
- No. It makes it almost harder because
my life is a dichotomy for-
You know, when I was in school,
I didn't have a friend in the world.
I was like, just a weird,
just this weird kid.
- Wow.
- Everything I've ever been punished for,
expelled for, hit for, is
what I get paid for today.
But I, I just,
- Yeah.
- No, but it is.
- I got in trouble for talking.
Look at me now.
(laughs)
- But it is amazing.
- Yeah. Yeah.
I, but I think that that doesn't make you
necessarily a bad student or whatever.
I think that that's also
like kids learn differently
and we are all different and
I think that's, what's cool.
- Yeah. But you seem to be
more well adjusted than I am.
- Well, you don't see me at home.
(laughs)
No, I'm just saying
like you, like you say,
people don't know you at home, right?
- Are you inviting me over?
- No. I'm- (laughs)
- You know, what's weird.
People know, I don't
want you to give it away,
but these are taped.
What days before, right?
- Yeah.
- This is not live.
- So I'd never
miss an episode. So if you don't mind,
I'd like to say hello.
I know I'm watching.
- Do you?
(audience claps and cheers)
Hello.
- Oh, you're gonna say hi to me?
- I'm gonna say
- Say hi to me.
- What's up Howie?
- Say hi, Howie.
- Hi, Howie.
- This is so weird.
- That was amazing.
It's very inception.
- It is great. It is great.
Oh, you know what I'll do.
- (laughs)
- If you're gonna go to commercial,
this is what I wanna do.
- Okay. Okay.
- At home, Howie, when you're watching,
turn around with your
back to the television.
You walk toward the camera
and press your breasts
up against the lens.
- We need another break.
(audience cheers)
We need another break.
(laughs)